who the hell is the main villain of
Picard season 3 because it's not the
changelings
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so we have a mystery Jack Crusher has
something wrong with him his eyes keep
going red he keeps seeing a big red door
and then he seems to become the
Terminator every time he does now at the
end of the last episode they sort of
said that that was because of the
um genetically mod thing in his brain
that he got from his dad and that he's
causing hallucinations but obviously
that doesn't tell the whole story I
think that is a little bit of a red
herring
it seems to be because well it doesn't
explain the terminating thing and it
doesn't explain the red eyes thing so
there seems to be more going on now we
also now know that actually the main
villain isn't actually the changelings
now when Captain vidic lobs around off
and that thing appears and it talks to
him it keeps saying your ship your
people and from the advert we've seen
for the next episode he actually
threatens the changelings repeatedly he
says your structure is not as advanced
as you think you're basically just
liquid and he then uses some weapon that
basically affects vidic and stops her
from
you know being able to hold her Corporal
form
so there must be another villain a boss
villain somebody that's actually
powerful enough to not only give orders
to this changeling sect but also to
threaten them
who on Earth could it be well there are
a couple of possibilities but for this I
think we need to really think about the
Jack Crusher mystery but that goes back
to Picard
so
the changelings infiltrated daystrom
they stole several weapons from daystrom
but they also stole the corpse of
Jean-Luc Picard
it seems to be at some point after that
they realized they needed Jack Crusher
and they started going after him big
time now it seemed to me that if they
knew that before they attacked daystrom
they'd have actually gone after Jack
Russia first to avoid exactly what's
happened they're running out of time
they need this weapon or whatever it is
they're planning ready for Frontier day
and that is only now a couple of days
away so it seems logical to me that when
they took the corpse of Picard they
didn't know they were going to need Jack
krusher so that says to me that there's
some sort of maybe DNA thing going on
here that they need
compatible DNA I.E Jack his son to make
whatever it is their planning work
so we'll maybe assuming that unless
they're so incompetent that they decided
to steal the corpse first do the
distraction and then go get Jack who
nobody knew about and they could have
very quietly taken months earlier if
they really wanted to what about the red
icing is that a big hint
well the red icing really just point to
the par wraiths now the changelings
obviously were in Deep Space Nine so it
would maybe make sense that the main
villain is actually the parath the
villain that we saw at the end of the
Dominion War the enemy of the prophets
now the changelings would potentially be
very scared of the prophets and maybe
even the power wraith because at the end
it was the prophets that completely
vaporized their entire fleet as it
passed Through the Wormhole so that
might explain why vitik is so scared of
this boss creature also have to remember
that the prioriter and non-corpora form
they're an energy being normally seems
like fire demons now we believed that
they were basically eliminated but
obviously enough time has gone by that
this might be their plan but will the
power race really interested in
defeating the Federation
they seem to be interested in defeating
the prophets I'm not quite sure how
we're going to explain that switch it's
possible that somehow Jack Russell is
actually being used by the parade like
goldacock did at the end of Deep Space
Nine
I don't like that idea I hate that idea
I never really liked that whole bit in
Deep Space Nine for me the finale of
Deep Space Nine was like three episodes
before the end and then they had the
whole thing with Cisco the prophets and
the power race and that just bit like
tacked on at the end it didn't interest
me the Dominion War for me was the
really interesting part of Deep Space
Nine that whole bit just seemed like
another bit so let's hope that's not the
way they're going it's very spiritual
it's very religious it's very big sci-fi
and I'm hoping they've actually got a
better idea
but another possibility I thought of
actually was maybe the Borg now before
you do another video
telemetalis does seem to have a bit of
form
he will set up one possibility he then
very quickly goes another way he seems
to like throwing in little red herrings
he seems to like throwing in I think
semless in the wrong direction and then
he comes back to maybe what he hinted at
in the beginning so when I say the book
I'm talking about how in the first
couple of episodes wolf 359 was
mentioned a lot lacutus was mentioned a
lot in the last in a couple episodes ago
when she was talking about it he said
locutus a borg so bad he's the only one
that gave a name to now I'm wondering if
that is a big hint that we might
actually see locutus return at the end
of Star Trek Picard season three but why
would the Borg need to use the
changelings rather one they're quite far
away two every time they have gone Toe
to Toe with the Federation they've lost
first time they were lucky fair enough
second time they were defeated and the
Federation has been improving his
defenses ever since the the Federation
is ready for an attack but also they've
learned from their encounters with
voyager and Janeway the Federation is a
significant threat that caused massive
damage to the Borg Fleet Voyager in
January was also very influential during
the conflict with 8472
again a conflict that massively damaged
the Borg's capability to fight
so perhaps the Borg are still in a
weakened State still back over in the
Delta quadrant licking their wounds
and perhaps they're using the
changelings in this proxy war to wipe
out the Federation so what is this whole
thing with Picard's body
well
we know that obviously he turned into a
book he had the implants Etc and they
were removed but it seems from the start
of first Contact that he can still
connect with the book he can still hear
them there must be some residual
technology left in Picard's corpse
perhaps that's what they need to trigger
or whatever it is they're doing this big
threat that's going to wipe out
Starfleet I'm also wondering so why
would they need the DNA well because
Picard's dead maybe they need a another
body to transfer across to to create a
new locutus so maybe Jack Crusher will
be that vessel that body that they use
or maybe they just need his bloody DNA
to kick start Picard I don't know but
whatever it is it seems to be connected
but the main reason why I genuinely
think the bulk are going to be involved
it's a big TNG finale how can you have
Picard season three how can you have
what they keep calling the TNG movie
they wish they'd had the finale the TNG
crew deserve without the Borg
it seems to me that they are the biggest
bad guys from the TNG and bringing them
back
really disappointed Us in season two
maybe we can see the real Borg in season
three
this is just a theory I don't know for
sure but I do seem to think that
terminalis is hinting and point us in
this direction as I say though he seems
to like to do that and then send us in a
completely different direction
but what about the elephant in the room
and I'm just gonna discuss this quickly
Kirk's body now when I saw that I just
assumed that was a way of setting up
that Picard's body was also at daystrom
we saw the little thing and the printout
next to Kirk's body that actually there
was something called project Phoenix
this is a heart back to actual William
Shatner's books where Kirk was actually
brought back from the dead Like a
Phoenix from the Flames there's also
theories that they were going to
actually create some sort of genetically
modified being from the best and
brightest of Starfleet
possibly but davestrom is basically a
weapons facility it's a where they hide
all of their most dangerous technology
so whatever purpose they have for having
Kirk Picard in whoever else is corpse
there it's not going to be good that has
led to the theory that maybe Kirk will
return
William Shatner still looks good he
could get up there and he could pull the
part off and fans would go crazy but I
think it was a red herring I think it
was just a setup for wiper cards body
was there anyway just to explain why
Picard's body was there but if William
Shatner did return even for a brief
comedy or maybe episode 8
damn that would be cool but I gotta say
I am loving pecan season three I am
excited for the premiere each Thursday
and I cannot wait to see how they wrap
this series up
it's a great show
however Tomatoes decides to take it I'm
certain we're gonna bloody love it so
well guys get to the comments and tell
me what you think what do you think this
story with Jack Crusher is it's not the
brain thing is it there's going to be
more to it but what do you think and who
is this finale villain who is the big
boss who is the big bad tell me what
you're thinking if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can support the channel
even more by going to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack or you'll get to
see most of our new videos before
everybody else on YouTube there's also
load of other links in the description
for lots of side trick related stuff
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]